Right this way guys.
You live in mainland China.
Yes. Okay.
Do you bring anything from China
to the United States?
No. You have a good day.
Thank you. How are you doing?
Good.
What's the purpose of your trip?
What did you do?
Just hang out the weekend.
I just wait over there for him.
I noticed that he was very blunt,
and I asked him, why didn't he go
to the Dominican Republic,
which is a source country for narcotics?
And he just quickly said,
I just wanted to have fun.
So I want to talk more to him
and engage more in a conversation with.
He’s got two bags. We’ll get them.
These both yours? Yep.
All right.
Follow us way.
We got a lot of questions for you.
First of all, are all these
your bags in front of you?
When did you pack your bags?
All right.
You packed them by yourself.
Anybody give you anything to bring over?
A step back.
So why did you go to the Dominican
Republic?
How many days?
A lot of stuff to take
for just four days or so.
Why all the cookware.
You bought this down there?
So your mom gave this to you
in Santo Domingo?
Oh, she gave it to your friend. Okay.
Something spilled.
Onion shampoo
that for you?
Do you use this shampoo?
Not too many people
come back with two bottles of shampoo
when they go on a four day trip.
It's a good concealment method for a lot
of narcotics and shampoo bottles.
They figure we're not going to get
our hands dirty and do a thorough check.
And get the Gemini
for me. We'll do a test on.